[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Hawaii is the
only place in the US
where humpbacks breed
and nurse their young.
[WHALE CALLS]
Born with very
little fat, calves
would soon freeze to death
in the cold waters of Alaska.
Mothers come to these
clear shallow waters
to avoid predators.
[SPLASHING WAVES]
But there's a catch.
There's no food here.
The moms go hungry, losing
up to 40% of their weight
raising their calves.
[WHALE CALLS]
It's a sacrifice that pays off.
Humpback populations
are increasing.
The park is just one place to
see these giants of the deep,
but they are not its
biggest attraction.
Two massive volcanoes are.
The first Kilauea.
One of the most active
volcanoes on earth.
The lava lake inside this crater
can be more than 750 feet deep.
Its lava flows can reach
the sea 10 miles away.
Kilauea is so big, that even
its vents and craters are huge.
Starting in 1983, one of these
vents erupted for 35 years.
It produced so much lava that it
covered the coast road, burying
it more than 100 feet deep.
To the west is the
second volcano,
and it's the biggest
on the planet.
This is Mauna Loa, rising more
than 56,000 feet above its
base, much taller than even Mt.
Everest.
The park exists
thanks to eruptions
over hundreds of
thousands of years.
Where hardened lava forms a
solid foundation for life.
Close to the source, poisonous
gas fumes escape from hot vents
called fumaroles.
This landscape is often
swept clean by molten lava.
It's one of the most barren and
toxic environments on Earth.
Nature has had to adapt to
living in this land of fire.
A wingless larva cricket.
After an eruption, she
is the first creature
to take up residence in
this hostile landscape.
The ultimate pioneer.
No larger than a
fingernail, she survives
by eating morsels
of food that billow
in with the ocean breeze.
Nobody knows where she
comes from, where she goes,
or how long she lives.
In many ways, she's a mystery.
[MUSIC PLAYING]